first thing I do as a clinician if
someone comes to me and says they're
depressed is ask myself a question are
you depressed or do you have a terrible
life or is it some combination of the
two if you're depressed you don't have a
terrible life you have friends you have
family you have an intimate relationship
you have a job or a career you're about
as educated as you should be given your
intelligence use your time outside of
work wisely you're not beholden to
alcohol or other Temptations you're
engaged in the community in some
fundamental sense and all that's working
now if you have all that and you're
feeling really awful you're either ill
or you're depressed now maybe you're not
depressed you just have a terrible life
what does that look like you have no
relationship your family is a mess
you've got no friend got no plan got no
job you use your time outside of work
not only badly but destructively you
have a drug or alcohol habit or some
other Vice pornography addiction you are
completely unengaged in the surrounding
community